plus de mille milliards d'euros de la
banque centrale européenne et des états
qui s'accordent finalement sur un
soutien de 540 milliards d'euros les
aides et financements accordés aux
entreprises et aux banques du continent
sont inédites
pourtant les critiques sont nombreuses
pour juger l'action de l'union
européenne
pour mathilde andrew et secrétaire
départemental du rassemblement national
des yvelines est élu en mai dernier au
parlement européen les institutions
communautaires se sont réveillés bien
trop tard pour aider les pays les plus
fragiles
l'europe est globalement a raté
complètement son entrée dans la dans la
crise clairement il y avait une division
des peuples un abandon total notamment
de l'italie et ça a été très flagrant et
d'ailleurs je pense que les italiens
sont maintenant très remontés contre les
institutions européennes
là il était nécessaire pour leurs
propres sauvegardes ailleurs de mettre
de l'argent sur la table des reproches
et les républicains également
françois-xavier bellamy ancien
conseiller municipal de versailles et
tête de liste de son parti il ya un an
estime lui que l'europe n'est toujours
pas prête à affronter une telle crise et
ce malgré son expérience
aujourd'hui c'est la crise l air
hier c'était la crise migratoire donnant
ce sera peut-être un défi sécuritaire ou
militaires il faut qu'on puisse se
donner les moyens par exemple d'avoir
une vision stratégique claire sur la
question de la santé
mais ça doit être aussi le lac et sur
l'agriculture fao est aussi le gage que
les questions de sécurité commune que
nous puissions garder à l'esprit que ce
qui compte ce n'est pas seulement le
marché européen à gauche enfin mounir
satouri ancien élu local aux mureaux et
eurodéputés écologistes jugent que c'est
surtout le manque de moyens mis à
disposition de l'union qui nuit à son
action je pense profondément quant à
l'europe qu'on mérite la santé la
gestion des crises sanitaires n'est pas
une compétence européenne est en fait on
est toujours dans ce jeu de reproches
sur l'institution européenne
quand on est en difficulté et on a
raison de le faire
sauf qu'à aucun moment les et amandes
les citoyens consomment on a fait le
choix que la santé était une compétence
communautaire
la problématique des compétences de
l'union européenne devrait agiter
bruxelles ces prochaines semaines crise
financière en 2008 2
la dette en 2010 des migrants en 2015
est désormais sanitaire en 2020 l'europe
doit agir une nouvelle fois dans
l'urgence d'une actualité sans répit
pour elle